bonjour à tous et merci pour votre
présence
alors samedi dernier pour la dixième
fois
des centaines de commerçants n'ont pas
pu travailler pour certains d'entre eux
ils se sont fait détruire leur outil de
travail encore saccagé leurs boutiques
des centaines de français n'ont pas pu
sortir l'insécurité reste très
importante nous pointons aujourd'hui
l'incompétence du gouvernement sur ce
sujet et la situation ne peut pas durer
nous ne pouvons pas chaque samedi
infligée aux français des villes mortes
des villes désertes et avec des
répercussions économiques très
importante donc nous demandons à ce que
l'ordre revienne
nous demandons à ce que le gouvernement
le président de la république met tout
en oeuvre pour qu'enfin les français
puissent à nouveau circuler vivre et
travailler dans de bonnes conditions les
samedis qui vont suivre
nous ne pouvons pas nous installer dans
cette situation nous l'avons déjà dit il
semblerait que le président de la
république ne salert pas de ceci le
ministre de l'intérieur non plus
puisqu'on nous dit que ça va mieux mais
le ça va mieux ça ne suffit pas car des
policiers sont encore agressé des
journalistes aussi et la violence règne
nous demandons à ce que tout ceci cesse
concernant le grand débat nous y
participerons parce que nous sommes un
parti de gouvernement nous agirons avec
responsabilité et évidemment nous
oeuvreront au mieux pour que la
situation s'améliore et que le pays
sorte du chaos
contrairement au front national avec
marine le pen ou à nicolas dupont aignan
qui eux aggrave et excite pour avoir
plus de chaos
nous nous ferons tout pour que la
situation s'apaise
s l'objectif du président de la
république nous posons la question car à
ce stade nous avons eu à faire plus
qu'un grand débat à deux meetings de
campagne électorale de logorrhée qui
apparemment
n'apaise personnes et qui en tout cas ne
permettent pas de sortir de la situation
que nous connaissons aussi nous posons
officiellement la question combien coûte
aux contribuables les meetings de
campagne d' emmanuel macron puisqu'il
est dans cette perspective de campagne
électorale pour les élections
européennes
et ben si le contribuable doit payer ça
nous voulons le chiffrage et nous
voulons savoir aussi quel parti sera
réintégrée au compte de campagne dans
marche sur les autres sujets donc nous
allons nous dans le cadre de ce grand
débat
consultez nos adhérents et faire des
propositions car nous sommes un parti de
propositions
la politique c'est pas seulement poser
des questions mais c'est surtout
proposer et nous par ce biais nous
reviendrons vers vous pour vous donner
les modalités de la consultation qui
aura lieu au sein de nos adhérents et
des différentes propositions qui seront
faites
si vous avez des questions je suis à
votre disposition
bonjour simon le baron de france info
sur le grand débat vous nous l'avez dit
vous estimez que ces meetings sont des
réunions publiques avec des maires sont
des meetings de campagne payée par
l'état par le gouvernement par le
contribuable
très clairement vous avez vu emmanuel
macron candidats
d'ailleurs il s'en félicite même et son
entourage aussi il se félicite d'avoir
trouvé le candidat de la campagne
présidentielle il tombe la veste
il fait état de toutes ces réussites et
il est en campagne donc ce n'est pas
normal c'est pas ça le débat et c'est ce
que nous dénonçons alors vous savez il a
déjà berné une première fois les
français avec une campagne électorale
j'espère que les français ne se
laisseront pas berner une deuxième fois
sur un tout autre sujet on a beaucoup vu
dans les médias notamment ce week end
monsieur bel ami pouvez vous nous dire
s'il sera la tête de liste des
républicains pour les élections
européennes
à défaut quand sera annoncée la tête de
liste et question subsidiaire sur la
position de monsieur bellamy sur lies vg
il a répété une conviction personnelle
mais pour nous rappeler que la position
officielle des républicains sur ce sujet
alors concernant l'investiture de notre
tête de liste c'est le 29 janvier que
sera uni la cni la commission nationale
d'investiture
et c'est à ce moment là qu effectivement
nous vous annoncerons la tête de liste
concernant françois xavier bellamy vous
noterez qu'il a contesté les propos hier
du des délais raccourcis et la
caricature qui a été fait
la position de la droite sur le sujet de
l'avortement est très clair a toujours
été très clair
évidemment et il est hors de question de
revenir sur la loi veil
bonjour paris afp hier jean pierre
raffarin a rappelé d'une part qu'il
était toujours adhérent à court de
cotisation je sais les républicains et
d'autre part il a proposé à ce que le
mandat législatif soit raccourcie à
quatre ans de manière à ce qu'ils soient
déconnectés du mandat présidentiel est
ce que c'est une position sur laquelle
les républicains réfléchissent nous
n'avons pas réfléchi sur cette
proposition en particulier car pour tout
vous dire nous sommes sur des sujets qui
sont plus des sujets de pouvoir d'achat
des sujets de 2 d'immigration de
sécurité
et c'est vrai que à ce stade nous savons
bien qu'il y aura éventuellement une
réforme des institutions
mais ce qui compte pour nous c'est les
sujets du quotidien des français donc
c'est pas une question que nous nous
sommes posée jusqu'à présent vous
remarquerez que la légitimité des
députés n'avaient pas été remis en cause
avant l'arrivée des députés en marche
car effectivement nous avons eu affaire
à une élection toute particulière ont
été élus beaucoup de députés qui étaient
totalement déconnecté du territoire et
c'est ce qui explique aussi la crise
actuelle des députés qui n'était
absolument pas sur le terrain donc
aujourd'hui on se pose des questions sur
l'action des parlementaires
ceux qui en sont responsables c'est les
députés en marche en place qui ont pensé
qu'ils étaient aux ordres du président
de la république plutôt que d'être au
service de leurs concitoyens et ça fait
partie effectivement de la colère des
gilets jaunes de voir ces personnes élus
qui ne sont pas beaucoup venus les voir
pour beaucoup d'ailleurs on le voit bien
là il profite du grand débat ils sont
assez contents de se dire tiens on va
aller rencontrer les français comme si
c'était pas leur travail au départ voilà
donc les institutions à ce stade ce
n'est pas une discussion que nous avons
menées nous en interne mais nous
prendrons sûrement position mais
peut-être pas particulièrement sur la
proposition de monsieur raffarin
pourtant des incertitudes
on sait quelque chose qui revient
beaucoup dans des revendications de
gilet jaune ce soit par rapport au
rythme par rapport à d'autres choses
vous vous n'en faites pas votre priorité
notamment dans notre future implication
dans grand débat nous ce qui compte pour
nous c'est que l'ordre revienne
qu'est-ce qui est entendue aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'on entend dans les
manifestations et qu'est-ce qui était à
la base de la colère c'est la fiscalité
trop d'impôts trop de taxes pas assez de
pouvoir d'achat c'est une priorité
absolue
le sujet de l'immigration aussi même si
effectivement on l'a vu pour le
président de la république ça semble pas
être un débat ce sont aussi des
questions qui comptent pour les gilet
jaune
il y à la question du référendum oui
nous sommes pour le référendum c'est
dans notre adn
et d'ailleurs nous avons proposé des
référendum est d'ailleurs des référendum
faisait aussi partie de notre programme
pour la présidentielle mais je pense
qu'il est essentiel avant tout de
redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux français
de redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux
retraités de baisser la fiscalité
d'améliorer la sécurité du français ces
sujets là sont prioritaires j'ai entendu
aussi qu emmanuel macron éventuellement
penser sortir de cette crise en
proposant un référendum qui ne porterait
que sur les institutions s'il pense que
proposait la limite ici on limite la
diminution du nombre de parlementaires
suffira à calmer la colère du pays
je pense qu'ils se trompent je reviens
sur les européennes
les sondages sont mauvais pour votre
parti est ce que cela vous inquiète et
comment vous expliquer cette tendance
alors n'ont pas commencé la campagne
donc j'espère bien que nous allons
convaincre avec notre projet avec nos
candidats nous sommes déterminés nous
sommes le seul parti qui permettra aux
français de voter contre emmanuel macron
et pour l'europe et cette position là
elle est essentielle et je suis certaine
que c'est une position qui aura toute sa
place et que nous parviendrons à
convaincre avec cette position réaliste
et pour une europe justement
conquérante qui protège ses frontières
qui protègent ces entreprises qui
protège ses emplois avant même la
désignation possible de françois xavier
bellamy comme tête de liste
une polémique est née sur sur ses
déclarations sur l'image et à la lumière
de ces polémiques est ce que vous pensez
qu'il a le profil pour rassembler la
droite
bonjour merci d'être là je ne sais pas
qui vous êtes pardon d'accord chanter
donc j'ai répondu à votre collègue tout
à l'heure françois-xavier bellamy vous
noterez qu'il a contesté les raccourcis
et la caricature qui a été fait par le
jdd à droite
notre position est claire sur le sujet
de l'avortement
il n'est pas question de revenir sur la
loi veil
si nous aurons fini je vous remercie
beaucoup